drink responsibly please
drink whatever you want
don't serve me that though hey guys my
name is danny taylon i am the owner of
the mia blanca mescaleria and today we
are going to be reviewing
these celebrity tequilas so the first
one we're going to go ahead and try we
do have santa tequila by sammy hagar and
van halen and guy fieri this tequila
used to actually be adam levine with
sammy hagar so this is santa tequila
fino and it's a blanco one of the top 20
tequilas in the world
let's see
bottles all right i should pour it out
like he hasn't looking like
it smells like hand sanitizer so i mean
doing a panda make why not you know i
guess
oh
that's gonna be a no so it is an 80
proof tequila did guy take us to flavor
tone he did not all right guys so next
up i hate to do this because i love him
this is nick jonas is a villa one i mean
it's villa but villa one and he did this
with john barbados it says it's life as
it should be clear bottle no story
nothing just i guess to the point so
let's try this one out
all right so
there's not much of a smell to this it's
kind of just there it has the smell of a
rubbing alcohol but very very very light
no um sorry guys i love him but this was
not it look at the jumanji cast rolling
the wrong dice all right guys so next up
we are going to try with all this these
accolades behind her i wish i had braids
on and a hat and i was in a horse
pulling up miss kendall jenner's 818
tequila blanco she says they work
closely with local family-owned uh forms
and jalisco to bring you the smoothest
most natural and best tasting tequilas
possible only the highest quality
ingredients are used in this creation
they all say that so she basically says
that the reason why she named a18 right
here in the water is because it's home
to her
but the earth is home to all of us
i guess she heard the backlash on
putting in a person that was mexican
behind her but this is one of the things
that we actually need to touch base in
just because the person is brown does
not mean that that's some sort of
affiliation with it being a good tequila
or anything like that it turns into one
of those cash grab moments if you're
getting backlash for something and it's
something that you can fix just learn
about it
all right so with this 818 i'm reading
this and it says that it's smooth
and natural
but there's no smell to it all right
let's i guess let's try her cheers
do you guys like cereal or marshmallows
this tastes like marshmallows
how long does it eat some water
there's a lot of sweetness to it kind of
only makes me wonder what is being added
to this it almost has like this cinnamon
taste to it
do better all right guys so next up we
have
motorcycle diaries george clooney
casamitos i see this being ordered a lot
this is the only tequila that i can
actually say someone has not been do you
have george clooney's tequila like it's
actually been like do you have cost
amigos bottle is in it whatever it says
that it's tequila 100
yeah these shots are getting to me
why do you order this
i knew it all right so the bottom of the
bottle says notes of a smooth vanilla
finish
guys
drink whatever you want to drink but if
your tastes like vanilla what are they
giving you this just came out am i
pressed a thousand percent adam levine
with his wife but hottie just made a
tequila
kelly rosa callie rosa has no story on
it but if you go to the website you will
actually see that it is a mexican fusion
blended with a california lifestyle what
the hell does that mean i have no
[ __ ] idea you guys know this song
that sugar song when i read the
description that's what i felt like this
was like papa bottom like
so he did this tequila with a tint in it
uh he said he ate it in some barrels to
get that tone
did you though
oh you guys so this is kind of cute this
is their bottle their bottle is actually
nice their
top is all glass look at you adam levine
he said victoria's secret money where on
the tops girl
cheers
y'all
so it has this smell like tarty it's not
pungent it's just tarty
oh damn okay uh um uh i just swallowed a
flower what i'm so confused it's very
very floral but it smells tarty but it
doesn't taste like what it smells would
i tell you guys to try this
yeah but to try it because i want to
know like y'all are tasting the same
thing if you wanted to buy this sip it
neat don't don't blend it in a cocktail
it seems to have like some sort of like
balance to where you wouldn't need to
add anything to it it's different it's
different like i can't even tell you
if i like it y'all this top though is
really cute
he released two so he released a uh rosa
and this uh
this one is set to be in a barrel for 18
months there's supposed to be some sort
of a toffee and vanilla which is like
what i hate the most vanilla any tequila
y'all
it smells like starbucks
[Music]
sorry guys
cut real quick
guys
guys i knew it i knew it trust your
instincts adam
adam
bahati
i mean if you want to go buy something
that's going gonna do the trick i
suppose but the trick is gonna be is
just gonna numb your mouth the smell is
different from the taste the smell is
like okay starbucks what's up let's wake
up but then it's like wake the [ __ ] up
that's not the wake up i wanted
so ranking you know on the presentation
i mean i would just give it to adam to
be honest like it's gorgeous your bottle
is nice it's an aesthetic there's an
aesthetic to this tasting wise though
this one is the most memorable i
honestly thought i was gonna grill it i
don't know i'm tasting flowers thank you
for watching let me know how you guys
feel about these if you so happen to
find them at a bar so you don't have to
like spend on the bottle go for it
people want to say that it's cultural
appropriation and things like that i do
believe that celebrities can work to
help out granted i get it it's your
first time but this is what i mean when
i say that people should actually
research it takes years to do something
like this
[Music]
you